c'était le 6 février 1973 à paris des
enfants suivaient un cours de musique
dans une salle de collège d'enseignement
secondaire rue edouard pailleron
il était à peu près 7 heures 20h20 20h30
le feu se déclarait dans une salle de
classe se propager rapidement 20
victimes
c'était un enfant qui inconsciemment
avait mis le feu aux 6es
mais ce collège avait été bâtie selon
des procédés de construction nouveau
léger rapide
on apprend aujourd'hui l'inculpation du
plus haut responsable de cette
construction de ce genre de construction
un haut fonctionnaire monsieur jean reno
actuellement conseiller à la cour des
comptes hier directeur des équipements
scolaires et universitaires le collège
d'enseignement secondaire de la rue
edouard pailleron dans le 19e
arrondissement avait été ouvert à la
rentrée d'octobre 1970 c'était un
bâtiment moderne de quatre étages qui
accueillait 900 élèves 55 100es de ce
type ont été construits en france c'est
monsieur jean reno alors directeur de
l'équipement scolaire universitaire et
sportif au ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui avait présidé aux choix du
procédé de construction modulaire et
conclut le marché portant sur les
établissements du type clape ce brevet
de la société métallurgique anglaise
brockhouse je construis un seul ace par
jour avait dit monsieur foucher en
défendant son budget de l'éducation
nationale devant les députés en 5 en
effet de 1965 à 70 près d'un million de
places ont été construites
il s'agissait à l'époque de faire vite
face à l'accroissement des effectifs
scolaires le 6 février 73 à 19h45 c'est
le drame un garçon de 14 ans qui se sent
mal aimé par ses professeurs achète 2
litres d'essence légère du white spirit
et avec la complicité de cinq autres
élèves
mais le fait l'établissement en quelques
minutes tout s'embrase
on retire des décombres d'un corps j'ai
été bouleversée je suis j'vous le dis
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
d'abord de temps de en tant que père de
famille bien sûr en tant que
fonctionnaire du ministère d'éducation
et à ce dernier titre je n'ai pas
conscience et je sais que je ne suis pas
responsable du drame qui a été
déclenchée par cet incendie
je crois que c'est vous monsieur le
conseiller qui aviez choisi ce type de
construction j'étais à l'époque
responsable au ministère de l'éducation
nationale je ne peux pas vous dire vous
répondre d'une manière précise à la
question que vous posez parce que les
procédures sont complexes que les
chaussons sont difficiles ne sont pas
simples mais comprenait aussi et je vous
prie de m'en excuser que je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui ici et à cette heure
dans ces circonstances vous en dire plus
car ce serait anticipée sur ce que je
dois au magistrat instructeur
on a bâti employant au miracle le diront
les experts commis au lendemain de la
catastrophe par le juge sablayrolles
pour étudier le dossier technique du cvs
malgré les inculpations déjà prononcé
contre 6 personnes
l'association des victimes avaient
l'impression avant l'inculpation de
monsieur raynaud qu'une certaine lenteur
judiciaire s'opposait à la découverte
des véritables responsabilités
cette inculpation c'est l'aboutissement
deux années de recherche des
investigations que nous avons poursuivi
pour comprendre ce qui avait pu se
passer le 6 février 1973 donc deux
années pendant lesquelles nous avons
appris beaucoup
compris beaucoup quant à la politique de
construction à la manière sur la manière
dont était construit un certain nombre
d'établissements scolaires ici dans ce
pays et nous avons constaté que plus de
80 établissements aidés frère jumeau de
celui ci et que près de 2000
établissements dans toute la france dès
construit suivant des procédés
industrialisés léger d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d' incendies ont eu lieu
après pailleron souvenez-vous à nice
ensuite à sarcelles et ensuite à
canteleu qui tous ont ravagé totalement
les bâtiments avec une rapidité tout à
fait effrayant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]